musk tells solar city trial that tesla
would die
if he wasn't ceo this is a reuters story
elon musk insisted in court that tesla's
board controls
the company but also said the electric
vehicle would would die
if he wasn't a chief executive as he
ended his first day of testimony on
monday in defense of the tesla's 26th
and acquisition of solar city
the lawsuit by union pension funds and
asset managers alleges the celebrity ceo
strong armed tesla's board of directors
into depleting
the company's asset with a 2.6 billion
all stock deal for solar city the ceo at
the time owned
a roughly 22 the cob and elon musk's 22
stake
in both tesla and solar city which was
founded by his cousins
and some tesla shareholders alleged the
deal was aimed at bailing out musk's
investment in the solar panel company
kicking off a two-week trial
in wilmington delaware musk testified
that he has tried very hard
not to be the ceo of tesla but i have to
or frankly tesla is going to die yeah
thoughts i think he's got to be really
really pissed off and it comes through
in his comments right here like
the nerve of these shareholders what
have i done to you
with your with the wealth that you've
attained through tesla stock and you
want to try to hang me on this little
technicality that's what great
visionaries do they take shortcuts every
now and then
they figure out ways to do it because
they got the guts to do it they think
they can get away with it
you know what this trial is interesting
he's had a verbal teta-tete with the uh
the
other lawyer in this civil trial i mean
they went at it in day one
but i i believe musk 100 that he would
not want to be tesla's ceo anymore and
i'll tell you why
he's not having fun i just don't think
it's a fun job for him anymore there's a
lot of issues
you know just dealing with what he has
to do maybe having the sec on the
horizon now too
you know a shortage of supply you can't
really get a tesla if you want one right
now
and he sees these other billionaires
having fun
flying off into space and he's got a
space company too but he can't spend any
time on that because it's dealing with
issues and problems
he'd give up tesla in one second if he
could but it would fall apart
yeah and and he's been infiltrated by
some far-left proxies
off you know that he's hired people that
have turned out to be political
operatives against them
and they get in specifically to try to
convince all his employees to unionize
and he's he said he's like why the
second you unionize you lose all your
tesla stock why would any of you want to
do this
like so um look man i'll tell you this
i am a shareholder in tesla and i
uh i i've put my deposit down i support
elon musk every chance i get
elon musk is either ousted or sells i
sell i'm out 100 i don't invest in tesla
i invest in elon musk
and i think that that i represent a
majority of those shareholders and i
think he knows that
and he said on multiple occasions he's
like guys threaten me again
i'll take this company private just one
more time just one more time don't let
me do what i want to do with my own
company and i will pull the plug i don't
need the money i will take this thing
private i'm going to give you a
completely different perspective
from what you guys just said here he's
playing with fire
and here's what i mean by he's playing
with fire um
so so a a company is like a government
you have to realize
each company is like a government it's
got the people in the middle who are the
best people to bounce ideas off of
because they'll be like okay let me
think about it and then they're
reasonable
yeah i don't know about that i don't
know if i like that idea and they'll
sincerely tell you
i don't know if i like that i'm talking
about his fellow executives yeah i'm
talking executives yeah i'm talking like
board
executive people you're working with so
you got the c-suites you got the board
right
there's people in the board that are
like yeah you know that's we should
actually consider
you know what why don't we have a couple
people run some numbers here and see
what that looks like if we were to make
a half a billion dollar investment into
that
that right then there are those that no
matter what he says they're going to say
no to
then then there are those that no matter
what he says they're going to say yes to
right so then there's gridlock on the
board when there's gridlock in the board
the founder
the driver the ceo loses his or
her mind when there's gridlock this is
why you're talking 51
rule or if your name is uh mark
zuckerberg
you keep it at 26 and you're out of
delaware which means you still have 2x
amount of votes which is 52
so you can still have control no matter
what anybody else says even though
you're not a 51 percent owner you can
still set it up that way to have the
influence right
but at the same time you have to know
that the no people
the people that are just automatic knows
they're typically the ones that are more
pro-government
and more you know uh uh you know
regulations some of that
yes they're bureaucrats right so they're
a little bit uh afraid of what could
happen
so they're one step away if you piss me
off
i may not be able to do anything to you
but i know how to make your life a
living hell
okay which means going to who oh they're
litigators they go right there
they go not to lawyers buddy with the
scc they go back to
making his life a living hell so and
these are people that he put on his
board that would do that
not necessarily he put on a sport so he
can nominate some people to be on his
board others can nominate to be honest
board you don't necessarily have
everybody you choose to be on your board
i don't understand how that works can
you
give me like a two minute on that okay
so let's just say you come in and you
say i'm gonna put a i'm gonna raise a
billion
i'ma race let's start a small company
okay okay
it's it's it's the two of you start a
small company together
and but you're getting two point like
even yesterday i'm interviewing the the
dave's killer bread you know dave's yeah
great i'm interviewing the guy right
they start the business they go from
doing 200 loaves a week to doing 500 000
loaves a week
he says we don't have money to because
we keep running out of money we don't
know what to do
so then eventually flower foods comes in
and buys them out and now they're doing
10 million a week
loaves of bread per week he gets 275
million dollar cash deal
but out of the 275 million dollar cash
deal he only got 33 million dollars
why poor guy here's why here's why
because
when you're growing you don't have funds
so you have to go grow and raise capital
so you come let's just say to me and you
say pat we need about 10 million dollars
i said i'll give you 10 million
great in return i want you to have a
seven-man board seat
out of your seven-man board seat i want
three seats okay
that's how it works gotcha so you say
okay so the four-board seat is gonna be
what you
tom and you pick whoever else the two
are and i bring my three
the go with the money guy is to maybe
win one more board seat
if i win one more board seat you can
come up with all the craziest ideas you
want but that doesn't necessarily mean
that your ideas are going to fill up
it's like a corporate filibuster in
other words kind of like what's going on
right now in senate or
congress where it's like a you know
blockade or nothing really gets oh man
that's kind of a deal with the devil so
you need the money to run your business
but then they take your business
and from you yes so it's not just to
share so many times people think when
you're bringing a money person in
you're worried about the you know the
equity you're giving up no it's the
control you're giving up so
tasmanian devils like elon musk
don't do well with control but he has to
understand
you're not worth 50 million you're not
worth 20 million
you're worth 150 to 200 billion on a
monday you could be worth 120 friday
could be worth 200 billion
the gdp of a small island it's
absolutely the gdp
of a good-sized island right okay
so if he goes in the offensive the way
he is
he has to know all the money in the
world even if he's worth a trillion
dollars the government doesn't give a
[ __ ] how much
you're worth regulation has the
government has a history
of ruining people's lives who have a lot
of money that think they can open their
mouth and say anything
he has to understand that and he has to
make some friends
or he's gotta be willing to go all in if
he does go all in
if he does go all in there are way too
many people that will team up against
him there's a country that doesn't like
him too much you know what that country
is called
he went in thinking he can make a deal
with them and what did they all of a
sudden do
oh yeah yeah yeah bring your cars over
here we'll do a deal with you we learn
everything about what your cars are you
know what get out of here we're good we
got we got to figure it out that
country's name is happy
happy 100th birthday that's right that's
right so egalitarian
all i'm saying to all i'm saying about
what he's doing right now and by the way
another i'll give you another part when
you say the company would flop without
me
okay now imagine you're the cmo of that
company
you're busting the ass working 80 hours
a week the ceo says
the company would be nothing without me
do you really want to work for that ceo
well keep in mind they don't do
marketing though so they what do you
mean they don't do market a form of
marketing
is putting your stores in the malls and
that's that's a form of marketing
okay a form of marketing is that video
advertising no i know that but a formal
marketing is you make a video for
instagram youtube twitter that's all
marketing right
imagine you're his cfo imagine you're a
cro imagine your ceo
imagine you're his president and the guy
says you guys are not going to do
anything without me
you think there's cohesiveness on the
team right now i think there's a certain
part of a rift going on right now on
that team because
there's only so much c-suite executives
can take you to say dude i'm gonna go
somewhere else to be appreciated so
again it's for the board is forcing him
to pin himself against
his executives it's not a good look so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye